una jornada que por ahora se desarrolla
en total tranquilidad de los 67 mil
puestos de fundación están habilitados
en este día en todo el país puesto que
abrieron a las 8 de la mañana y que
cerraran a las 7 de la noche incluso 8
de la noche en las ciudades más
importantes del país en cuanto al
ambiente muy distinto a lo que se vivió
hace dos años cuando se realizaron las
elecciones municipales primera vuelta
que se realizó dos días antes del primer
confinamiento en medio de la pandemia de
kobe 19 dos años más tarde por la
situación es ha cambiado hay una
pandemia sí pero ya está controlada para
poder venir a votar en puestos de
votación como que ustedes ven a mis
espaldas en realidad no hay mayores
reglas se pueden utilizar mascarilla si
se quiere se recomienda sin que las
personas más vulnerables las personas
que tengan síntomas y en incluso
aquellos que tengan coi 19 pues la
utiliza así que aquella persona que
tenga como puede venir a guardar dentro
de estos puestos de votación hay gel a
disposición de todas las personas e
incluso auto texto para los jurados de
votación en caso de ser necesario en
total pues son un poco más y 8 millones
de personas las que están inscritas en
las listas de votación y en los últimos
3 meses o incluso 650 y 50.000 personas
que se inscribieron por primera vez se
trata al parecer de personas que fuese
que acaban de cumplir la mayoría de edad
los 18 años y que podrán hoy por primera
vez ejercer su derecho al voto